[Musique]
ayant été impliqué dans l'orbiteur solaire
pendant plus de 13 ans, ce fut un
moment incroyable de voir les premières données et images
car c'est quelque chose que j'attendais en
tant que scientifique depuis de nombreuses
années et en suivant tout ce processus
depuis la conception de l'espace  de
le construire et de le lancer et de
le voir fonctionner réellement en orbite est fantastique
[Musique] [
Musique]
[Musique]
ces premières données nous permettent de régler le
logiciel sur les cartes pour calibrer
encore mieux les images afin que nous puissions nous
préparer pour le  phase scientifique réelle et pour
des approches encore plus proches du Soleil
[Musique]
vous